okay we played clips from the whatever
podcast before on this show and uh I
just want to play this one cuz this
one's kind of nice because it's a a very
very viral clip from that show so the
point is this if you had IQ and skills
to offer to the marketplace you can earn
a good income being that the most
valuable thing about you is something
that you never earned you didn't earn
knowledge you didn't earn skills it's
your breast that you're paid for and
your butthole so you Market that to earn
money which is to say if I took your
brain and placed your brain into a man's
body you would be impoverished it's like
they've never even heard anyone tell
them that hey you know this is you
actually shouldn't do this okay you're
you're worth more than that selling off
your body parts is a bad thing you're
worth more than that you shouldn't do
this